hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreign again today's the
ending of season 9 which means our
slowly approaching season 10 but we also
have some season 9 facture and more to
talk about so as always like the V if
you do enjoy subscribe for new I cover
the informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates and the petulance and the leaks
shouldn't be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update though if we stay subscribe to
the channel and with that let's get
started so credit to everybody within my
discord I do appreciate that guys thank
you guys so much for sending me all the
images I am part of the Knights and the
Vikings one of course they've won like
five seasons in a row or some [ __ ] so I
didn't actually get a chance to get a
picture of what the ornaments and all
the stuff looks like so thank you to the
people within my discord specifically to
Gander strick ace and URI thank you guys
for sending me your images I'll be
gladly using these throughout the video
just in case you're a little bit lost on
where the faction war is currently the
Vikings won by taking four out of the
five campaigns the Knights came in
second because they took one and the
samurais were in third place because
they didn't take any of this season so
but it look next time guys
hopefully the Vikings will actually end
up losing for once I sadly do not
actually have a picture of the emblems
that it comes with but I do have the
outline and I also do have the ornaments
but we're gonna go diving into the
outline to for you a little emblem here
real quick but this is what the emblem
looks like if you're part of the Vikings
this is the gold border and of course
this bout line or border looks the exact
same for every other faction except a
different color so the night circle
there's gonna be a silver and the
samurai yours is gonna be an a-type a
bronze color while the Vikings this is
exactly what yours looks like since you
are the winning faction it looks like
four mini blades are peeking out of the
corner with some intricate designs
around closer around the edges of course
but slowly coming into the middle I do
appreciate that a lot
I'm not a big fan of outlines that go
are very congested and keep coming
towards the middle of the piece like for
example when the Knights won back in
season three I believe we got one that
was super congested in the middle and it
didn't look great because you could
barely see what your actual emblem was
so I'm really glad that they actually
have this so it's a pretty simple design
not more of a big fan of simple types of
outlines like this so I'm totally cool
with that next up we have the ornaments
the thing everybody cares about we're
gonna go in order of the factions on the
hero selection menu so the so the
Knights go first the Vikings go second
the samurai are third in the
our last and of course remember since
the Vikings won the season faction they
of course get these ornaments and they
get equipment on any single character
that they want within the game but only
if you're part of the Viking faction and
the ornaments are faction based meaning
the Knights is gonna look a little bit
different from the Vikings and compared
to the others of course and this is
gonna be the knight ornament it's called
bored occurs Bane that's gonna be the
name of the ornament so if you're a
Viking player and you're wondering which
one it is
it is the Vorta Gers Bane so definitely
go grab that it looks like a bat
originally to me but I can kind of see
where it looks like a dragon head or
some type of a devilish look on the
front it looks a little bit misleading
from this picture with the gladiator
just because the silver matches with the
silver but honestly not too bad of a
piece comparing to most of the knight
things in terms of ornaments I do
believe that the most of the Knights
have a better headpiece I'm not sure how
this would look on Peacekeeper
considering the fact that her ornaments
at least in my opinion or utter garbage
but I think this can look nice if you
have a character with a helmet on like
most of the Knights moving on to the
Vikings and like I said this is gonna be
a little bit different from the knight
so the Knights have a huge big skull on
the front whereas the Vikings have a
little bit of a smaller skull but some
things protruding out of it which might
look like legs or bones sticking out of
the sides you can tell it looks really
nice there's this big-ass horn in the
middle too of course with the wings in
the back as well personally to me not
too bad of an ornament I'm not a big fan
of any really the faction ornaments
either so I'm usually going to dislike
these by honestly this isn't this isn't
really that bad next up we have the
samurai and this is probably one of my
favorite ones out of the three so far
because this one has a lot more designs
while this is still the dragon piece or
whatever that skull is in the front it
has a lot more towards the top making it
a lot more intricate and that's usually
what the samurai have the big flashy one
so I definitely definitely fits their
aesthetic and I think that this could
actually fit well cause like I said they
have these big flashy ornaments and any
small ornament but just that really
doesn't look too good on most of the
samurai characters an example can say
most of his ornaments that in my opinion
look good or the bigger flashier ones
but that could just mean me so honestly
if I did play a samurai specifically
can't say I most likely would have it
equipped on his head and the last one we
have is the Wulin now personally I can
already tell that I do not like this
ornament I might just because of Shaolin
with his bald head and this just doesn't
look right on him as a character he like
I prefer him to have more of the crown
desk ones and
nothing really like this but honestly
it's a lot smaller than the other four
it still has the wings very small
intricate pieces throughout the middle
but that's really about it nothing too
flashy about this at all if I had to
give my top four from best to worst I
would probably say the samurai are first
with the Knights being in second the
Vikings in third and the woman being
last but that's just my opinion I looked
at our thoughts in the comments which
ones you think are good or if it these
ornaments are good at all definitely let
me know down there as well hey guys it's
going to be the end of the beta hope you
guys did enjoy it like I said if you
have any thoughts about these ornaments
are they good are they bad definitely
let me know I'd love to start a
discussion with that personally from
what I've been experiencing with the
past nine seasons since I've been
playing even since the beta these
ornaments haven't really been that great
I feel like to get more people
interested in the faction more they have
to add better things than ornaments have
a round of executions or some type of
mythic out but something to actually
give people an incentive because at
least for me and maybe for you guys as
well I haven't really cared about the
faction more maybe until since like
season forward that could just be
because I plays the Knights and we
barely ever win so I kind of lost hope
but that could just be me but honestly
I've really haven't cared too much about
the faction war so the ornaments aren't
really that great either so I don't
really care if I don't get that yeah but
always guys like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe for new my to marches and
videos are gonna be popping up on screen
if you guys want to check that out join
the Twitter and the discord if you guys
wanted to be active and those I highly
appreciate that and with that I have a
great yesterday enjoy those ornaments if
you are the Vikings and peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]